foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
whatever the hell day it is Tuesday
probably look Tom died his beard again
yeah
it's getting like more more evil Spock
as the days go on I like it you know
what I mean
we you are right yeah you want to be on
the show or yeah I'm on a show okay
a lot of [ __ ] cell transfer and [ __ ]
yeah well [ __ ] yeah that's to uh uh
bee's nest I sent it dude I just sent
you on your thing the [ __ ] phone
number it went to
all right hopefully you sent it to the
right place yeah I got the little I got
the little thing right here in the
account it's the same one that I've sent
it to before
yeah I don't know about Zell but yeah I
think it's mostly cash app that I have
trouble I don't have trouble with it
it's just sometimes stuff takes a long
time to show up well I think Zell sends
it to her cash app
really cash app I think of the same
thing no they're not they're not okay
then it's the Zell it was it was well
Zell you have to like send it that's
from bank account to bank account yeah
yeah you know what I mean because when
people send me money with Zell it just
shows up in my Bank of America okay
that's how that works whereas cash app
it shows up in the app and I have to
transfer it to my Bank of America all
right you know what I mean okay it
wasn't cash up in Brazil
uh Zach says I think Tom's Hubbard
impression was one of the best things
I've ever seen I demand it Beyond every
show now okay so you have to do lrh on
every show now oh that's ridiculous
we all know that
it's kind of similar to your BTK but
they do kind of sound the same a little
bit your lips have to come out a little
bit more and you have to be jovial and
it's a lot like Colonel Sanders you know
you got to do you got to do duck lips
yeah
we know that his his mouth looks like a
grouper yeah like seriously there are
trillions of alien civilizations out in
the universe and they're they all and
they all can they all speak with me I am
the original source and you know I can
take you up to the bridge of no return
no what was it called the original
Freedom Bridge the total freedom it's
actually the bridge of no return though
well yeah the bridge yeah it broke ass
no money yeah I'll take every bit of
your money make a [ __ ] a wizard
yeah yeah Zach said also my new job
started today it's so cool and I'm
loving it so far that's good I hope it
uh continues to be awesome
Hugo said I just started to watch your
Jeffrey Dahmer episode very interesting
gosh I don't even that was a while back
we did that one uh yeah stop it stop it
stop it hey hey just turned to June uh
Mr 88 said is this anything like the
quiet Earth no
interestingly this how did I did I not
know about this movie this is one of
those movies we were just like looking
for a movie to watch we were gonna do
the Night Flyer because that was like
somebody said about it like you can
watch it for free on YouTube I think but
I didn't it was another Stephen King
adaptation so then Tom was like looking
for somebody's like well I kind of want
to watch terrify her too but I guess
that's not available to stream yet
because I was like oh yeah that sounds
like a good idea but I guess it's not or
at least it's not on a streaming service
that we have even though we have most of
them so he's like well I kind of want to
see something new so we go to shutter
because they've added a bunch of new
stuff but then we were going through we
saw this old movie from the 80s
and Tom's like that sounds kind of cool
and I was like I've never even heard of
that it's like and it had like a pretty
high rating like it had four skulls out
of five and I was just kind of like
let's give that one a whirl and see
what's going on and this ended up being
really good this was like a Hidden Gem
and I kind of feel like first few
minutes just the way the establishing
shots and the little score that they had
going I was kind of like yeah all right
I'm digging it
it it's uh
it's a decent flick yeah I actually I
actually really liked it it's
it's basically a uh it's a b movie all
right yeah yeah they I mean I looked I
dug around about this because this
there's not a lot of information about
this movie like you can find out about
it it's not like that anymore but
it's not one that uh people bring up
very much but I did find out they um
this cost 350 000 to make which even
back in the 80s was like nothing so
considering how low the budget was and
considering I don't know it was like
kind of a cool story like how it got
made
um and Fred said and I was going to
bring this up the plot sounds like the
60s movie Carnival of Souls it is kind
of like Carnival of Souls but not it
doesn't like um turn out the same like
in the broad outlines it's kind of like
Carnival of Souls but this movie is
actually more like a precursor to Final
Destination which came out in 2000 so I
kind of feel like the makers of Final
Destination maybe saw this movie
because the plot is very very similar to
the first Final Destination movie and
this also gave me it's not exactly the
same but it gave me the same kind of
vibe as it follows
so I'm assuming that the people that
made it follows maybe also saw them on
it's maybe not but it did kind of give
me that Vibe too it's kind of like uh to
me it's tonally it's a lot like a very
early Carpenter movie it would have
played pretty well with a very early
Carpenter movie with you know like on
cable or VHS you know what I mean you
could have played it right alongside
Carpenter and like uh like a early uh uh
[ __ ] what was the one like a rabbit
or something what was the name of uh
David Carnival yeah kind of like a
Cronenberg kind of on a movie now is is
it as good
no but it's not
that different really it's not that much
worse if you were a kid watching them
you really you'd like the Cronenberg and
the ones better just because they were
more bizarre
but this wouldn't fit right in with it
you know
this is good Interiors yeah this one has
like a really really creepy yeah tone to
it honestly even though it came out
here's the weird thing I looked at the
copyright thing at the end of the
credits and I'm pretty sure it said 1982
if I'm reading my Roman numerals
correctly but it didn't get released
until 1984. like in Spring of 1984 it
just got like a limited theatrical
release
but I kind of feel like in it almost
feels more like a 70s movie than an 80s
movie you know what I'm saying yeah like
it reminds me and yeah and I saw like
another review of it that kind of
compared to Carnival of Souls obviously
because that's the most obvious
comparison but they said totally this is
almost kind of like let's scare Jessica
to death like from the 70s and I was
like yeah it has it's not as weird as
that or like as vague and strange as
that one but um it's kind of like
similar in tone it does give me more of
like a 70s Vibe than an 80s Vibe but I
respect that the guy that directed this
which I'm sure like if horror fans will
know who it is but um his name's Tom
Eberhart this was his first feature film
and the year after this I believe he
would go on to much more success with
Knight of the Comet which I know we
haven't reviewed yet and I know a lot of
people have asked me yeah yeah yeah like
well like after the end of the world
yeah so it's the same director okay and
uh so I kind of feel like that one is oh
and this this is the same guy because he
only did those two horror films he did
Knight of the Comet which like I said is
everybody horror fans know night of the
Comet
um but he went and did comedies later he
actually did Captain Ron what's that
wasn't that the movie with uh Kurt
Russell Kurt Russell was in that right
in Captain Ron uh he did Captain Ron
that was early 90s and he also did Honey
I Blew Up the Kid which was like the
sequel to Honey I Shrunk the Kids right
the second or third one yeah so he did
comedies like later on but so this was
his first feature film now I really like
though that when he decided like him and
the woman that's in this
um playing uh the psychic actress lady
uh she was actually like a producer on
this too and they were like well we just
want to make a movie that's gonna like
make a profit you know what I mean so
they're like well we can either do like
a sexploitation movie like in a manual
movie or we can do a horror movie and
they're like well let's do a horror
movie but this was the early 80s and it
was kind of like slasher movies were
really big but I like that they were
like they could have very easily like
just done a slasher but they didn't do
that they did something like a lot more
atmospheric and I think that I mean it
does have Smasher elements I guess like
in the sense of you know people do get
you know stalked and killed and stuff
but it's a lot more of like a mood piece
and I kind of like respect that they
went in that direction the thing about
it was that even though it got only a
limited theatrical release
um apparently it did pretty well like it
was a pretty mod like a moderate success
but the people that made the movie like
the producers and the director and stuff
didn't get any money because the
distributors [ __ ] him over so there's
so there's that
um if it wasn't like a Smash Hit or
anything like that but it would have
made money back
um but the distributor is kind of like
[ __ ] him out of most of the money that
[ __ ] sucks yeah so yeah it was kind
of a shame and it actually like it was
apparently such a nightmare that uh the
woman that plays the main character in
this that plays Denise she had only been
in one movie prior she was in a movie
called girlfriends like in 1978 she
actually got a Golden Globe nomination
for that and then she was in this and
because of all the [ __ ] that happened
like with the Distributors and the
[ __ ] nightmare and everything like
that she quit acting it was like [ __ ]
this and she moved back to the Midwest
it like just did something else because
she was like yeah forget it I don't want
to be involved in that nonsense anymore
but uh but yeah and it's kind of a shame
because this is actually I mean I'm not
saying it's like a masterpiece or
anything like that but this was like way
way better than I was expecting it's not
bad and I couldn't believe that I had
never seen it or heard of it or anything
before says kind of like a crown an
early Cronenberg or an early Carpenter
it's it's in that ballpark it has a lot
of the same totally to the tone is kind
of similar the only thing that lets it
down in my in it has actually decent
acting and decent dialogue it's almost
kind of like it goes all [ __ ] Quentin
Tarantino on you sometimes with a lot of
[ __ ] just spurious [ __ ] side
I really liked the dialogue in this like
some of the stuff that they said to each
other yeah like it made me laugh out
loud yeah like and not because it was
bad because it was actually like
actually funny yeah you know what I mean
and it's kind of like um
you know the only thing to let it down I
think was the score the score is kind of
it's late to the score and I thought it
might have been a stock generic it
wasn't it wasn't okay but it sounded
very much like the 70s 70s let's see
that's what I liked about it because I
like that kind of all right mood it's
not I thought it was something lifted
out of [ __ ] like a 70s television I
don't think it was I mean they did have
a guy like that did the music for it and
everything it wasn't you know as good as
a cronenberger a Cronin well no but very
few things yeah or a carpenter
soundtrack your score you know Carpenter
at least come in there with boom with
his little [ __ ] rolling [ __ ]
synthesizer or whatever
[ __ ] you know that's it like from
Escape From New York but uh you know
not bad not bad uh the story wasn't for
me it was okay
wasn't as compelling as like say like
maybe like a carpenter or uh or a
Cronenberg but chronic would do some
crazy [ __ ] you know wasn't that crazy
but it was pretty good pretty good you
it's watchable watchable if you if
you've seen these other movies and you
haven't seen this one you should see it
yeah I'm kind of like if you liked
Carnival of Souls
um and you liked Final Destination or
you liked that I did this is almost kind
of like in the middle of those two films
you know what I mean like now I'm gonna
say like Carnival of Souls I love
Carnival Souls a lot of people do
Carnival of Souls was actually not as
original an idea as it might have seemed
because I think that there had been a
Twilight Zone episode a few years prior
that was called The Hitchhiker I think
was what it was called and it had almost
exactly the same story as Carnival of
Souls so
um so that's like not all that original
this one I kind of thought when it
started out I kind of thought oh we're
going in a Carnival of Souls Direction
like oh she's dead the whole time kind
of thing which like I said that's not an
original Trope either because that's
goes back to [ __ ] Amber's Beer's An
Occurrence at Owl Creek Bridge and all
that kind of stuff where the whole thing
is like taking place like before you die
and whatnot but uh so yeah so I thought
it was going to go in that direction but
it's not quite in that direction like I
said it's kind of more like Final
Destination so I know that the guy the
people that made Final Destination must
have seen this movie they must have yeah
because it's almost the same exact idea
what happens is there is
um a woman named Denise now at first
there's like an actress that she's
working with because Denise is like a um
she's like a TV producer like she
produces like commercials TV commercials
and stuff and this actress that she's
working with who's also a psychic like
basically like calls her up and to be
like I know you're gonna um take a
flight and probably you shouldn't and
they're like oh you're saying she's
gonna die it's like no she's not gonna
die
um but she doesn't get the message
Denise doesn't so she goes on the flight
and the flight crashes and everybody
dies but her
so then like as the movie goes on she's
going about her regular life and she
kind of like has these consultations
with a doctor because she's like
unscathed there's like not a not a
scratch on her so she has these
consultations with a doctor the doctor
is like well maybe you have survivor's
guilt like a lot of people have that
kind of thing and she's like no I don't
feel like Survivor I'm not guilty or
anything like that she's like I just
feel really odd and then like later on
she's like I almost feel like I'm about
to be caught like I did something bad
and like somebody's coming after me so
then like as the movie goes on like she
starts seeing much like it follows she
sees like people that are just kind of
like standing there like looking at her
you know what I mean like in a creepy
way and it turns out that these are like
dead people they're not ghosts and it's
not like it follows where only the
person that it is following can see them
these are actual dead people that are
walking around technically zombies this
part of the movie was kind of reminded
me of that old movie [ __ ] Barry what
was it buried alive buried alive yeah
yeah yeah it's kind of like that too I
hadn't I hadn't thought of that before
right but Khan just jumped in he says
never heard of this movie it's kind of
like it's good forgotten B movie on on
par with like an early Cronenberg or
early Carpenter
if I could you'll recognize a lot of
it's real similar
and it's about a girl who survives a
plane crash and the dead people are
coming up out of the ground trying to
get her basically yeah or they're
they're more like walking out of the
morgue walking outside it's like recent
dead people but like I said they're real
dead people because the people like
they're people like hey the body
disappeared from the morgue like where
the [ __ ] did it go she was supposed to
die but she didn't so the Dead's Waging
War against her see like I said that's
exactly like Final Destination and I
know you haven't seen Final Destination
but well Final Destination okay if we're
being technical
if we're being if I'm in a well actually
the [ __ ] Final Destination and I've only
seen the first one
um and maybe the second one but I can't
remember they are fun but you know the
first one's really the only one you need
to see in Final Destination they
technically didn't survive the plane
crash because they were gonna get on the
plane but then one of them freaked out
and said oh my God the plane's gonna
crash we're gonna die so they don't get
on the plane but then like they see the
plane take off from the airport and then
they see the plane explode and so they
didn't they didn't survive the crash
they were just like no we're not getting
on it because they had a premonition
that it was going to explode and then
after that they get killed in like
really ridiculous like accidents you
know what I mean like they're driving
behind ooh thank you Trey thank you Trey
killing it lately guys more so than ever
thank you so much why are we key on it
man give it to tell us why we're killing
it that way we'll keep it coming like
yeah I guess all the topics and talking
about all right that's because he said
something about that uh earlier
when uh he commented something on one of
our videos but yeah so but yeah in Final
Destination so it's basically like they
were supposed to be on the plane and
they were supposed to die in the crash
and because they didn't now they're like
in this weird liminal space where death
is like trying to get them and like kind
of come claim them so they die in these
like increasingly like gory and
improbable accidents like they'll be
driving behind like a logging truck in
the log like like you know impales them
and [ __ ] like that so this is kind of
more like that where she's kind of like
but also the dead people that are coming
together also killing other people like
around her too and then those people are
coming back from the dead and trying to
get her you know what I mean so it's
like I said it's essentially the same
plot as Final Destination so I don't
know if the makers of Final Destination
saw this or
um when I was digging around about like
kind of the history of this movie there
was also a novel that came out in 1976
by James Herbert who also separate the
rats and the fog he's like a big like
well-known horror writer and he wrote a
story called The Survivor which was also
very similar it was like about a person
that survived a plane crash and then all
kind of like weird [ __ ] happened now
that book was made into an Australian
film called the Survivor in 1981 that
actually had Jenny agatar in it and uh
apparently is like really really good I
haven't seen it but it's not like
exactly the same as this but it's like
similar there's a really lot like when I
was looking through there there's a
really lot of like stories about people
that survive
um a crash and then like weird [ __ ]
starts happening you know what I mean
actually you know what I didn't know was
that you know the M night uh Shyamalan
movie Unbreakable yeah actually
um he I don't he didn't get sued but
they actually when they read the script
they were like okay you have to change
this because it's too similar to the
James Herbert novel The Survivor that I
just brought up which was like I said
actually a plane crash and not a train
crash but other than that was like too
similar so he had to change it uh
because otherwise they would have sued
him so there's so there's kind of a lot
of stories about that about somebody
that survives a crash and then they're
either dead the whole time or death is
like coming to claim them or something
like that so I don't know but it's just
really weird because when we were
watching it I'm sitting there going like
I saw the beginning and the beginning
part's really cool you can tell this is
like really low budget like I said
because it's only it only costs 350 000
kind of adds to the charm to make but
yeah but they did really well with what
they had and the thing about it is that
I was watching like a thing about the
making of it and they said what they
tried to do was they tried to get like
shoot in as many places that they as
they could for free like
the one the early shots like where
they're going in the bus and it's just
like all like deserted streets and stuff
they said the city was it Santa Ana or
Santa or something like that uh in
California and they actually like let
them film there for free and uh they
then they just shot in like people's
houses they used like some of the like
the director's car like [ __ ] like that
like instead of renting one and stuff
like that because one thing that they
wanted to do was they wanted to save
money on that kind of stuff like on
shooting permits and stuff so they could
actually shoot this on 35 millimeter
because they thought that that would
help them like get more distribution
because cheaper movies are usually shot
on 16 millimeter and it doesn't look as
good because then it has to be blown up
yeah
um so it this actually does look really
nice like it's shot really nice and
actually I think that the DP on this
went on to work with James Cameron I
think he was the DP on Titanic and like
some other [ __ ] too yeah like I said I
mean I put it up there with early
Cronenberg early Carpenter in terms of
quality
the story isn't quite as Innovative uh
not quite as compelling as something or
the other guys that come up but still
it's not a bad movie if you've seen
those other movies you should have seen
this one
it's not a bad story and then and they
have uh
a lot of good little scenes and they go
through some Quentin Tarantino style
[ __ ] dialogue and going off the
directions that was one of my favorite
things about it okay all right well and
it's weird too because it almost kind of
has like I think this was one of the
things that reminded me a little bit
more of the 70s was that Denise and her
doctor who kind of get into a romantic
thing and they almost have like a little
love story kind of thing going on there
which actually normally I would like be
like you know what I mean but actually I
kind of liked it because the the
interactions that they had with one
another in their dialogue and stuff like
that was just like so funny and like so
naturalistic like it had like a lot of
like dark humor to it and I really liked
that like you know what I mean I it
didn't have like this kind of stock
stupid horror movie dialogue it actually
had some personality to it and I was
like kind of into that and I don't know
and like some like even the early like
the first scene where they show the
plane crash even though it's very
obviously they can't show a real plane
crash because you know this movie was
like super low budget but they just had
like some stock footage of like a plane
taking off and then they just kind of
had this thing of like where they would
lay out presumably where the crash was
and there was all these people laying
around with like blood and like their
[ __ ] arms over here and one guy like
in half with his guts hanging out and
then it did a pretty good job yeah they
did a pretty good job and it's like and
Denise just like sitting there still in
her seat and these two seats are empty
and she's just sitting there like what
the [ __ ] just happened like with this
blank look on her face like she can't
believe it and she's like completely
unharmed and I was like that's just a
great way
if you don't have the budget like to
show [ __ ] I thought it was like really
effective you know what I mean the
strong part of it was um
of the production like uh was the uh
uh
where they shot it what am I trying to
say not the sets because they're not
sets the locations and the interiors
that they did which was just people's
actual houses of like people that worked
on the movie or whatever yeah but
there's and then they would like go to
like uh like a hotel seminar area or
yeah or something in a mall or something
or then they just drive down the street
but there's something about it that kind
of
gave it an authenticity there's
something very they were trying to get
the highest Tech and the [ __ ] coolest
looking locations they could in 82.
so the way that [ __ ] aged out it's kind
of like a a new retro wave music video
kind of come back around again as being
in style
and it's kind of for people me and
Jenny's age being you know X Generation
it's kind of like a walk down memory
lane seeing those old Interiors because
they're long gone that's just all
[ __ ] torn down or re-furbished on the
inside you just don't see things that
look like that anymore
and you remember it from your childhood
you know [ __ ] early teens you're like
how kind of crappy a lot of cool [ __ ]
crap [ __ ] that was supposed to look
really cool kind of looked a little bit
crappy
but you didn't think that at the time
it's just it's just weird you know I
actually really liked the uh still looks
cool the inside of Denise's house is
yeah which like I said I think from what
I could determine they just used they
couldn't afford to like rent any houses
or cars or anything like that so they
just used people's houses like the
director's house or whatever they used
offices and stuff there's people talking
about big corporate offices and they're
lit in a way to make them look real
mysterious looks like something
Cronenberg would do and interestingly
too like some of the scenes they shot in
the hospital yeah they actually that's
an actual hospital and they let them
film in there for free because they said
oh well there's one uh floor that we're
not using because they're doing
renovations or whatever so you guys can
shoot up there so they got away with a
lot of stuff you know like the
helicopter with all the medical
equipment on it like when she's coming
back from the plane crash and everything
they were like well you know they asked
they were like hey can we like shoot all
this new equipment and they're like yeah
sure why not we just got it so they got
a lot of stuff for free and so they got
to shoot on location in a lot of places
that they didn't have to pay
performances from the actors were good
nobody's founding phoning it in they're
they're really acting and they're
they're having fun yeah I didn't see
anybody nobody was just phoning it in
they were like yeah I'm a star now I'm
in the movie I'm in the scene you know I
mean you could just tell you could just
tell they were having fun making the
movie yeah even though I heard that like
the um this was actually quite a long
shoot I think was almost a month long
they said and they said there was a lot
of tension on the a set for whatever
reason but
um I mean I guess it like it worked out
good though and to be honest you can
really tell that the director this was
his first feature film and he was super
jazzed because when the producers came
to him and said hey we want to make like
a cheap ass horror movie do you have
anything like that
um because one of the producers like had
gone to film school with him and he was
like oh my God I have like such a good
idea for a horror movie so you can tell
that this was kind of like a passion
project this was actually something he
really really wanted to do and he really
felt uh you know really strongly about
making this movie this was the movie he
wanted to make and a lot of the people
that were on the crew and the actors and
stuff like that were people that they
knew that they had like worked with
before
um so I just I don't know I just thought
that was cool and the thing about it
was remember like I said the the woman
that plays Denise like she this was her
last movie actually after that after
this experience she was just like yeah
no I don't wanna I don't want to be an
actor so she just like went back home
well um just get [ __ ] yeah and and
honestly like I said the Distributors
really [ __ ] over the makers of this
film unfortunately and um so that
crooked business so that kind of sucks
yeah well and to be honest and I know
that this was their first film so they
probably didn't know because they signed
a contract didn't have to take care of
it and they did it in the contract like
ended up because they were like hey you
signed it and they were like well [ __ ]
they probably should have hired a lawyer
but maybe they couldn't afford it you
know what I mean uh you know you gotta
learn you got to cover your own ass well
he came back with that second movie and
that second movie is kind of a [ __ ]
uh it's a cult classic yeah you know
like it didn't do all I don't think it
did all that well at the time is he
still alive director
um I think he is yeah maybe yeah he's
still alive maybe he's watching it was
it was a good flick he liked it yeah
1947. and it came out had I seen it when
I was a kid I would have liked it a lot
of people I feel like um because I saw a
couple of other channels that covered
this movie because like I said I had
never heard of it like before we saw it
on yeah I'd never heard of it never seen
it on shutter and I was just kind of
like oh that sounds cool and so we
watched it I was like wow that was like
way better how did I not know about that
I never saw it in any uh video rental
store when I was a kid we would have
rented it
yeah but the thing about it is that
I feel like I don't remember seeing it
in video rental either
I'm sorry but it went down the wrong way
went down the wrong pipe
but um I saw like some comments on some
other reviews of this and people were
like oh I rented this from the video
store and like it really creeped me the
[ __ ] out when I was like a kid and I can
totally see why it would there's some
pretty creepy [ __ ] in this because it's
creepy for the same reason that like it
follows is creepy because it's always
creepy like because she's for example
she's like in the diner like talking to
the doctor and then she looks out the
window and there's a dude across the
street just standing there like looking
at her and it's like that kind of [ __ ]
always creeps me out yeah so I can see
why this would be really it's really
good I mean the atmosphere is like
really really good yeah they set the
tone in the opening scenes with the with
the nighttime shots outside of the town
and just the uh the score that was going
it was going good now like I said as the
movie kind of went on the score sounded
a little bit generic to me you know but
I'd only seen it once maybe on further
viewing I might change my mind but I
just I thought the score was a little
bit generic and you missed the end
because you went down and you had to go
you were working on you had to get a
free fried beans or something
so I had to tell them what happened
right yeah
that's another thing I want to spoil the
end but I will say that I like too that
it went for like a bleak ending yeah you
know what I'm saying so like it's
similar to Carnival of Souls but like
she's not dead the whole time she's not
dead the whole time it's more like Final
Destination I I I'm gonna put it there
with like a
like I said
kind of like an early Cronenberg movie
or an early Carpenter movie like that
yeah it was it fit right in with it yeah
it was warmer than a Cronenberg movie
yeah do you know what I'm saying not
quite as weird like cronenberg's movies
are usually like very weird like kind of
off-putting and like very chilly well
some of his interior shots with the
corporate speak and everything going on
and we're very cronenbergian I mean yeah
so there were parts of it but it also
kind of reminded me of dead and buried
too yeah now that you mentioned a really
good movie I like that one yeah dead and
buried like that's a really good one too
and I feel like that's kind of a
forgotten one as well maybe not as
forgotten as this one but it didn't even
hurt forgotten [ __ ] I never even knew
this one I never heard of it either well
and the thing about it too is that the
reason is I mean because it's called
Soul Survivor there's a bunch of other
movies called that so that maybe is why
too I think there was even a movie that
came out in 1970 that had William
Shatner in it that was called Soul
Survivor I don't think it didn't have
anything to do not a memorable title
that's what I'm saying and then like
later on there was one called Soul
Survivors s-o-u-l whereas this one is
s-o-l-e
um which I don't think I've seen but
I've heard it's terrible
um so there's that that was like two
early 2000s I want to say like late 90s
early 2000s that one was so yeah so
there have been a lot of movies called
variations of this so that might be a
little bit of why it's forgotten too but
you'd think because night of the comet
is such a big cult classic you'd think
that more people would know about this
movie because it's the same director but
and honestly I really like night of the
Comet but
is more like a horror comedy whereas
this one it it this one has comedy in it
but I wouldn't call it a horror comedy
like it's funny but this one's much more
like creepy yeah this one's creepier
very but like I said very much like a
Carnival of Souls kind of vibe it's not
as weird as that yeah but
it's kind of like along those same lines
it's kind of like unsettling you know
what I mean it has like an unsettling
Vibe we're seeing it through the context
of Our Generation and we know the time
that it came from so we understand it we
can put it into context I don't know
what a gen Z person think would that
would think of this maybe if they were
into old retro stuff like [ __ ] new
retrowave type music they probably
[ __ ] love it because I know there's a
Resurgence in 80 stuff you know so
uh but just like a random gen Z person
they probably wouldn't see anything in
this but
you never know that we speak the
language that the movie was written in
basically you know you guys know what
we're talking about we have the context
to understand it because we knew what we
we would know what this movie was
competing for around that time
and um surprisingly good I you know
it was a shame they got [ __ ] over and
didn't get paid for it yeah because
the movie needed some more exposure it
should have been on cable and it should
have been more easy more readily
accessible on VHS I think
um the title maybe didn't help it that
much the title isn't very Punchy or
catchy
doesn't and there had been similarly
things I'm trying to go back you know
when I was [ __ ] 13 or 14 or 15 trying
to rent a movie you know what I mean the
titles that would attract my attention
didn't wouldn't have sounded like that
too much although the cover art looked
pretty good
I'll say though that
for art to me like now that I'm looking
at it now that I've seen the movie and
now that I know that what the movie is
about like it makes sense to me but if I
was just like kind of scanning through
the cover art it looks like a sci-fi
movie it does it looks like cook and
it's not a Sci-Fi it looks like
something happened to a nuclear war and
AI or something
yeah because I mean what it is is like
it's a skull like it's supposed to be
like death and it's kind of like a um an
image that's kind of but it's a um it's
a plain radar like from the what do you
from the what do you call it the um
right you know from the radar scope yeah
from the radar thing so that's what it
is but the way I guess just like the
color scheme and stuff like that that
reads is sci-fi to me because it didn't
when I just kind of glanced at it didn't
look like a skull it looked like a like
a alien it's not though marketing was
probably a problem
considering that they probably that they
probably didn't have any money yeah yeah
it didn't have the right look it didn't
look bad but like you said you're right
that doesn't it looks like sci-fi it
looks more like and the font that they
use too
um read more as sci-fi to me right if I
had been on that graphic design job uh
which I wouldn't have been because I
would have only been like 10 or 11 when
this came out
um but had I been on that I would have
gone in a more
um like more traditional horror
direction or more like something that
was like creepier I would have gone more
towards dead and buried yeah
right I don't even know if I would
necessarily
I don't know I mean I guess she could do
like something with the plane crash
thing but I don't know I kind of feel
like that might be that was incidental
to the movie that's what I mean that was
just like the inciting incident so I
think that maybe putting too much
emphasis on that would have been like
because then if you did that then it
would look like a disaster movie and
it's not a disaster it's like a creepy
carnival you might have been trying to
Hitch it on to a disaster movies because
they were coming out of the 70s
so maybe that was I don't know it's hard
hard to think I'm trying to think of
myself and what their shoot what the
shoes were because they were wearing
very different shoes in the early 80s
you know uh they were uh they were they
were going into Uncharted Territory and
they were just were looking in back in
the 70s of what worked yeah they I mean
if you had you asked them they probably
thought that cronerberg and [ __ ] and
carpenter were failures or that yeah
those guys aren't that good no they were
pretty good
now they all have their own [ __ ]
half-lives you know Carpenter some of
those movies I don't even think he made
I think they said his name on him
I think [ __ ] Carpenter the thing
getting its ass kicked by E.T [ __ ]
Carpenter up I don't think he [ __ ]
mentally recovered from that
which I can understand why the thing was
[ __ ] panned and that [ __ ] is
a classic it's a [ __ ] masterpiece
so how would that make me feel after
making that [ __ ] I'd I'd be [ __ ]
pissed I'd be demoralized I mean I would
be too maybe tomorrow but you do have to
like have a little bit of perspective on
it especially in the horror genre it's
like a lot of times if you make
something that's like super super
brilliant
um sometimes it's not really recognized
until later on much later you know what
I mean that's just how this [ __ ] happens
we all grew up knowing what the thing
was that mother [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
Masterpiece but
you know [ __ ] the generation older
than us you know the Baby Boomers they
didn't understand the thing not the way
we did
Yeah well yeah they don't understand a
lot of things
I'm a [ __ ] as a [ __ ] Masterpiece
Dave Kennington said I'm with you on the
Eerie stare even though it's a comedy
for some reason the silhouette watching
from the window and The Burbs used to
creep me out as a kid yeah like The
Burbs even though it's hilarious I love
The Burbs but um it's hilarious but yeah
there's some creepy [ __ ] in that movie
and honestly there's something and I was
saying this while I was watching the
movie uh watching Soul Survivor last
night
um you know the first scene like when
she first sees like the first dead
person that's like looking at her she's
like and she leaves the hospital and
she's waiting for her friend to come
pick her up or whatever and she's like
back in the back parking lot like in the
loading area and there's like this
little girl and she's like wet and she's
just like standing there in the loading
are just like looking at her and she's
not she doesn't look [ __ ] up or
anything like that she's just standing
there and just and that is like super
super creepy to me I don't really know
why zag mentions that Blade Runner got
its ass kicked by [ __ ] TT also yeah
and I remember
people older than me like my like my
mom's age I wanted to see I was a kid
you know I must have been about 13 or 14
and I said was that Blade Runner any
good and they were like nah they didn't
like it
I could see how yeah they didn't like it
and that that [ __ ] and played him
Anaconda
kind of was panned and it it was like a
box office failure from what I remember
and then I saw it later I never saw it
in the theater I saw it on on VHS later
and it blew me away I [ __ ] loved it
couldn't stop watching it trying to
figure that [ __ ] movie out and that
was when it was hard to figure movies
out because they didn't have internet
you know see there was you can like
confer with other people yeah what the
[ __ ] was that all about yeah his eyes
really glowing is he a replicant yeah
um
and also no way of finding there was no
way of finding out
about the deleted scenes that were taken
out back in those days about what
happened with uh the first plate of the
first Blade Runner what was his name
[ __ ]
um
[ __ ]
there's there's a couple deleted scenes
remember the guy that got shot in the
very beginning by Leon shot him
what was that what was that blade
runner's name I don't remember
there's a scene where Deckard meets him
in the hospital [ __ ] and he's like in
a damn plastic tube and they're
breathing for him and they're talking
that was uh that was some [ __ ] wild
[ __ ] there was a bunch of stuff that was
deleted out of there
yeah
but that's I don't know it's just kind
of like
it's one of those things I I don't know
it's just I feel like nowadays maybe
people appreciate [ __ ] more than they
did back in back then but
you know you see something like the
thing which in hindsight was like so far
ahead of its time and it was like
different because like I said 81 that
was when all the slashers were coming
out I kind of feel like that's maybe
what happened to this movie too
um because slashers were so big
in the early 80s and particularly like
in the video rental market so if you
made something different I kind of feel
like people were like meh they didn't
really want to see it but I just wanted
to see another slasher and you know so
if you made something like a little bit
off or a little bit different or a
little bit weird like I think it didn't
really find its audience until later and
back then it had to find an audience
through word of mouth because like I
said we didn't have the internet so
that's kind of what happened and it's
now that I've seen this movie and looked
into the like his production history of
it everything like that it makes me kind
of sad that it didn't do better because
like I said it's not a masterpiece or
anything like that like don't get
excited but I'm just saying that this
was like way better than I was expecting
way better it's it's punching way above
350 000 big time yeah and like there was
some [ __ ] in here like legit creeps me
out you know what I mean which you know
that's hard to do there's some creepy
[ __ ] in here and it's a it's just a cool
idea it's not an original idea it's been
done before so sort of but
that's okay everything's been done yeah
everything's been done
um all you can do is really kind of come
at it from a different angle or you know
put a new spin on it or something like
that because you're not going to come up
with anything original there's no such
thing anymore
uh Zach said I really love poster art
from the 60s and 70s very graphic and
blocky I really love the ones where it's
like black and white photos with little
pops of vibrant color yeah I like that
too I was trying to think like when we
were talking about
the poster or the box art for this movie
and I was kind of like I'm trying to
think like I'm trying to put on my
little graphic designer glasses and be
like if I was tasked with making a
poster or box art for this movie
what what I do it wouldn't be anything
like what they did because that like to
me that reads like sci-fi
and I wouldn't do anything with a plane
crash because that reads like a disaster
movie but I'm not entirely sure what I
would do I
I wouldn't want to make it look like a
zombie movie even though technically the
dead people that are coming after her
kind of they're technically zombies I
mean it's this isn't a zombie movie I'm
not saying that but they are like
technically zombies because they're
walking dead you know what I mean yeah
they're just like coming together
they've been reanimated because they're
coming to get her because she's supposed
to be dead
but I don't know I'm just trying to
think of like I don't know maybe I'll
come up with something now now I kind of
feel like I should make a poster for
this it's better that's better than the
one it's better than the one they had
yeah the poster wasn't great the title
of it of the movie isn't all that great
really I think they could have done
better my uh it would I would have
changed the marketing aspect a little
bit
um
I put my main gripe is is that I don't
think the score
is good enough
it needs a deeper signature to
differentiate it from other movies
because it was going up against
Cronenberg
and and uh Carpenter at the time and
they had real strong
unique sounding scores
it wouldn't have cost that much and even
with the guy that whoever's doing the
score all I could like the opening part
the sound the uh the score in the very
opening scenes I liked it
I would have [ __ ] pushed him harder
to to make something
more more odd stranger something that
stood out a little bit more
more uh
I don't want to say New Wave
but New Wave inspired something with
synthesizer irikana
sound
they could have done better on the score
that's my only gripe can I use anything
outside that would have costed a bunch
of money it would have gone over budget
I'm talking about what you know I'd have
pushed how to push the score a little
harder
can I just say to you that if you're
real into if you're a fan of 80s horror
uh Brink Stevens very famed 80s scream
Queen makes an appearance in this movie
and shows her titties because that's
just kind of like well they needed
titties in the movie and she was I guess
she was the only a lot of titties in the
movie that was that would do that well
yeah I guess they got tickets in the
[ __ ] aircraft in the air crash in the
air that's right I forgot he had dead I
mean dead titties dead titties yeah if
that's if that's what you're into that
you're supposed to have that though this
is weird
you're trying to get teenage boy asses
in the seats watching this [ __ ] thing
yeah you better have titties so they do
have like a strip poker scene yeah uh
with Brink Steve I forgot about that
yeah who like I said bring Steven she
was in sorority babes in the
slimeballorama she was in a Slumber
Party Massacre she's been in a million
things yeah so yeah so she was like
boobs okay yeah the girls were all in
good shape they were in good shape yeah
so there is like some nudity in this too
and it's not like over the top gory but
there is some gore the way weird thing
about it is like the guy that played the
doctor
I thought he looked familiar so I looked
him up he was actually in ghost story a
couple years before this
um but weirdly he died suddenly like two
years after that I don't know what he
died of but he was only like 33 33. and
he just like died in like 1986 just
dropped dead I don't really know what
the [ __ ] I don't know if it was drugs
or I don't know but I was like okay
that's that's upsetting Zach also said
well people didn't appreciate uh Blade
Runner 2049 much either yeah I don't
understand it I loved 2040. I loved it I
loved it these [ __ ] are
[ __ ] man
and I and I liked uh dune I'm waiting
dude was pretty good yeah I don't think
they appreciated that either I think I
like 2049 better but Dune was good too
yeah it was just pretty good I like
2049. yeah I did it as well we saw it a
couple times in the theater yeah I got
it I got it on Blu-ray
Angela Lansbury died holy [ __ ] sounds
familiar how old was she yeah I can't
place her you know Murder She Wrote yeah
bed knobs and Broomsticks [ __ ] she's
120. she's got it yeah I
you know what's crazy Angela Lansbury I
remember seeing you know everybody like
my generation we knew were from Murder
She Wrote when she was already kind of
like an older lady yeah and then I saw
the adaptation of Picture of Dorian Gray
from the 40s and she was in that when
she was young and I was like holy crap
look at Angela Lansbury like she was
like super young in that and she's like
96. so exact same age as the queen damn
man yeah yeah
I mean yeah you can't that's like longer
than most I mean Jack LaLanne lived in
95 96. you know right [ __ ] with
juice in his whole [ __ ] life I hope I
lived that long he lived good and
jack-o-lane looked better than me at
[ __ ] 75 than I look right now Jack
was [ __ ] the [ __ ] so I sometimes
think about that though it's like
because I'm I just turned 50 in case you
guys don't know so I'm just kind of like
well I could conceivably like live
another 30 40 years maybe like maybe
even 50 years that's why but then
sometimes I'm just I'm just like I think
about that and I'm just like oh that's
awesome but then sometimes I think about
that I'm like oh my God that seems like
forever
I'm already so tired you got a plan for
the Long Haul man I'm so tired well you
gotta it's not so much that it's just
kind of like I'm gonna run out of money
before that happens you know what I mean
I think it's more you can't think like
that you just go to day after day well
that's what I try to do I try to do I
try to do like one day at a time one day
a day of the day and try to keep your
health good
and plan for the future
yeah like I said I try to do that but
you know how I mean you don't want to be
like my dad you know me for a long time
I'm not my problem more than anything is
that I think of like all of the things
that I need to do still
and I think of them all in Aggregate and
it gives me a panic attack because I'm
like oh my God like I have to do this
and this and this and this and this and
I have to do all of this stuff and then
I have to like kind of step back and be
like okay we're gonna do all that but we
have to do it like one step at a time I
have to do one thing at a time because
if I think about all the things that I
have to do
together then I'll freak out because I'm
like because I'll just get overwhelmed
and not be able to do anything you know
what I mean but I'm very aware that
that's how I am so I really have to like
every single day I have to slow down and
be like because I every morning I wake
up and I have like a list this is
everything that I have to do today I
have to edit this video I have to write
this thing I have to do this that and
the other I have to do this design
project and so if I don't finish
everything on the list every I start
panicking like at the end of the day
because I'm like oh my God I still
should do this that and the other and
then I'm like
but then I have to like chill out and be
like okay look you can just like copy
and paste it into tomorrow's thing it's
fine you know it it'll all get done just
one thing at a time because it's it's in
my nature to have to want to do like
three or four things at once and I
really have to like stop doing that
because it stresses me out I don't know
why I'm that way but that's just
that's just the way I am and it's like
hard to get over you know what I mean
yeah but um yeah I've honestly I I know
this is gonna sound shitty but I thought
Angela Lansbury was already done
I would have expected it I didn't
realize she was actually still alive so
that's kind of a bummer
but yeah like I said just made the jump
to hyperspace
she's she's where she dropped her body
you dropped her body like all right like
yeah
there you go see Circle the back around
Circle back around but uh yeah well I
mean if you like Angela Lansbury go
watch the um The Picture of Dorian Gray
the original was like the one I think
it's from the 40s I think right 40s or
early 50s I can't remember but it's a
that's actually my favorite adaptation
of it because I love that novel by the
way but yeah I couldn't believe how
young she was because I only knew her
from Murder She Wrote but yeah so uh so
I feel like we should probably wrap it
up for like an hour but yeah if you have
shutter
uh shutter just added this which is how
we just randomly stumbled across it and
if you like
I was gonna say if you like 80s movies
but actually more if you like 70s movies
because I feel like this has more of a
70s movie Vibe than an 80s movie Vibe
even though it came out in the 1980s but
if you liked Carnival of Souls if you
liked Final Destination and want to see
like something else like along those
lines or dead and buried this is kind of
like like that too then or it follows
then definitely like check this one out
because I feel like more people need to
see this one I had not even heard of it
and that's saying something because I've
at least heard of most things you know
even if I haven't seen them yet but I
hadn't heard of this one and uh yeah
that kind of sucks but yeah it's it's
really really good I I liked it a lot I
think I liked it more than Tom did but
hey I still appreciated it for what it
was though but yeah I mean I liked it
way more than I was expecting to I
thought it was just gonna be like some
cheap ass but yeah it was actually like
really really well done
all right so we will be back tomorrow
evening for our main show and I'm sure
Zach will be very excited because I
think Zach was the one that uh that
nominated this and it won handily we're
talking about Queen Victoria so we're
doing like a whole history like Queen
Victoria maybe like talk about the
Victorian era you know how she like
influenced it and stuff like that
because that's actually like really
interesting well like I said a lot of
people have been talking about how they
how much they like are um what that's
what you're talking about oh that's
nothing that's a that's an email thing
that's I gotta jump your email tell
somebody trying to bust into the
conversation no no all right that's just
don't don't worry about it that's just
hungry yeah I'm sorry okay all right so
uh everybody come by tomorrow at 6 PM
Eastern Standard time we'll talk about
Queen Victoria it'll be fun uh you know
because everybody likes kind of like
these historical figures that we talk
about so we're doing another one of
those so thanks for dropping by today
thank you Trey for the Super Chat
earlier and we will see you guys again
tomorrow